Parish deputies mayor for tourism and
sports a Jean Francois Martin joins us
from Paris city hall this morning good
morning to you mr. Martin good morning
we're so sorry that this has happened to
your city and we thank you for joining
us today you know there are reports that
there was a human chain used to take out
some of the artifacts from Notre Dame
can you tell us how that worked and what
artifacts were saved yeah thank you for
your kind words and a lot of very
friendship to emergency gold watch the
first one was to try to restrain the
fire and to reduce the impact it will
have on all the the building and a
second one was to preserve the culture
the everyday and of course the relics of
st. Louis but as well the part of the
criss cross but as well the the crown of
Jesus and so we made a human chain with
our friends from the the church from the
police but as well from the sitio public
servants make a human chain to get as
quick as possible all the reliefs
it's incredible to hear that you have
saved many of the relics that were
inside the Cathedral was there any
damage to the tunic of st. Louis
no fortunately thanks to the great
bravery of our firefighters but as well
of all the public servants there we had
a very quick intervention and so very
quickly team was fully dedicated to save
all these holy holy pieces and
specifically these relics and the crown
and everything is safe and and imagined
and so we are so in our really bad day
we had one good news is that we managed
to preserve it mr. mark chance what does
this loss mean for the people of Paris
he's a part of our history so a part of
our identity even you are believer or
not cut the catheter all not for them is
our middle age history it's specifically
at the place where the city of Paris has
been built at the very beginning of
Paris when it was a small city it was
just too wrong the place where the
cattle wall is rising right now so it's
really part of our identity and that's
why we are so sad this morning but with
a strong that we showed after the
attacks after everything that passed
through Paris the Parisians are strong
and they will rise up again and build it
again I will show that even in our
sadness we can rebound as every time we
believe you mr. Martens we believe thank
you so much for joining us this morning
we really appreciate you taking the time
you